hello reject nation
it's Greg Alva here and I am Tara rx10
here there's this clip out this teaser
clip out for a video rim wood which i
think is a sex position Chronicles of
the Dead the teaser clip the long a
theater clip them John who works that
Blum house had to watch a clip of this
and I'm he was like about to show it to
me and I'm like wait John no I've got a
request to check this clip out on the
internet I can turn that request I can't
watch this with you John I'm gonna bring
a guest on
slow your roll John and get out find
somebody else
why we go a trailer with you to watch it
with me on internet bro check let's
check it out ok
[Music]
Oh real romantic like that mess
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh good we are
oh my god
[Music]
nothing viola happening can't look away
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no girl yeah more violet anticipated
dreams
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the and where this all pretty well
[Music]
you broke your ankle oh yeah yes
holy [ __ ] oh yes woman money oh yeah I'm
like an MMA fighters get done girl no
you know no I know but you're handsome
[Music]
hi
[Music]
yeah yeah come on
[Music]
I survived
[Music]
like a month even thanks we met some pop
it into the water
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
nice visitor oh damn chicken fight one
more minute left Sarah
[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ] no no no but
[Music]
[Music]
my holiday
party hats on stormtroopers - you
persist
[Music]
[Music]
what was that that was so cool I'm gonna
be a TV show I think it's a movie it's
like a b-movie horror flick it feels
like Mad Max meets zombies oh my gosh
that was amazing who's crazy what's up
with those people and she runs through
they're also like nominees but they got
the white eyes are like nightwalkers
yeah then they have I guess there's some
zombies they can get the president might
be zombies you can control because why
she broke out the rosamma bees ever
clearly working with them wielding guns
and stuff but I thought they might have
just been like cliches and they my eyes
yeah they had a specific white out of
the black dogs so I'm wondering what
kind of zombie things are closed because
the scientists guys the really strong
scientist dudes apparently because those
are like uses like pick her up and toss
her around there's nothing apparently
scientists they work out a lot yeah
they'd have to in a day and age like
this doesn't tense that's crazy I love
well how fast-paced it was I love how it
is like the cheesiness was amped up
because it what the cheating this wasn't
like corny cheesy no I was actually
alien flavor in style yeah yeah it's
serious like doodling but it's badass
the same kind of hat ah ah who is this
girl didn't I call it as if she got a
breakdown of them change and then what
did you do I mean she broke her ankle
and then managed to still use that same
foot to kick really even looking around
the thing with the air conditioner like
no Bolton NASA
yeah gotta keep the story moving Gregory
I mean it's just be movie style man yeah
I love it Mad Max meets
zombies right we're all to the end when
they come over and they look down at the
like they're looking down at the other
zombies I'm like you guys are on me too
and when they open their mouth did you
like steam come out she says a lot shot
it was like one of those things from
like are you guys those are zombies that
also probably
the other gone where they look like they
were on the hunt I think all right you
know what I was just laid below coming
in from the thing no I'm your mouth
Oh is their mouth see wormwood movie no
holds bar retina blistering Austin
Australian top cool post-apocalyptic
zombie film headlong yeah oh dude I'm
into it dude
when does this come out because I uh
watch this
yeah yeah yeah yeah I like that girl
I want her to be my new protector in
life yeah me too
let's let's hang out you teach me some
MMA yeah right and then like I don't
know you just you need to be it could be
in my rocking chair on my porch and just
like make sure well the designs all sort
of how does this kind of throwback vibe
to it as well it did look I will call me
film I mean even though you know like
what are those outfits called this
radiation protective yellow yeah yeah my
me like the crazies from back in the day
yeah I like it a lot that was food I
know what I wanted to do was I play this
- me neither
Oh everybody's being grinded right now
was not expecting any of this to go on I
thought it was going to be a long trip
so many bodies grind it in that trailer
it's insanity badass she's fat hell yeah
well one day a score man no more yeah
I'm wondering what their world of the
zombies is supposed to be like because
it seems like they have a different
approach to zombies seems like when
you're first turned into a zombie
you're a regular zombie you just want to
eat flesh right but there's way you can
control them or communicate yeah clearly
how do you get to be a Wyatt family I
want to know about her I didn't really
know what is her world that she's a part
of or the group of people she met up
with what is what's really going on its
entirety the world is clear she was
kidnapped captured and they were going
to do experiments on her but I don't
know what exactly the world is that
they're treating you're more than just
you know another Walking Dead think is
clearly more than
and I just realized what I'm wearing the
right t-shirt for today okay
flooding dust Darryl from the walking
dead great Thank You Carol do it again
okay Carol for the walking guy all right
uh I see you're a big fan of that [ __ ]
well guys we're what movie hey you know
I'm gonna do it worried what early
wormwood here's what I'm going to do I'm
going to like your page right now
following you're like you today geez
liking things you're going to be a link
in the description box for the watch
this video in full strings you don't
just see their little box and at the
same time there's going to be a link in
the description box for this film you
guys got to follow these guys you need
more support only 60,000 Mike's right
now that's [ __ ]
hey I'll go find the other thing
muttering my facebook me probably read
into town looking for another person two
or three some move
over there I'll forget that threesome
going also if you have a child you don't
like and you want to give it to her
give it to taro take care okay then you
can actually sing